magic city is a strip club when you walk
in you throw money and girls get
complete Nicki if your record isn't
playing in Magic City then it's not hot
the streets
I think the strippers don't have a big
part of whether a song works or not if
you're a gentleman and you're in the
club and this girl is actually twerking
her life away sweating is shaking in
some of the convincing you that this
song is it the DJs and the dancers are
more like a n RS and we hear hits and we
love to dance soon we know what we like
dance to and we know it hit me here I
love you damn yo music is generated
usually first through the strip clubs
its underground grows from the strip
club and then it goes to the dance club
and when it graduates from the
commercial club it usually goes to the
radio if it's what makes them shake if
it's what makes them spend money that's
what they play fortunately for us
whenever makes them shake comes on
everybody eats somehow songs magically
just make people want to throw money you
know the whole culture it was like you
were in the middle of the music video
future might be mr. magic City he really
started like he's the one artist that I
know that every song every other song
strip club is a future song the way you
make birth disappear colored man is
sleeping on purpose in the other college
magic my life magic magic we made that
song leaving from magic then I made it
like it I made this song 11 o'clock in
the one
man to man be fake it till you make it
upgraded